hello everyone and welcome to the pen
ultimate round of the opera euro rapids
tournament uh it's a game that
took over 122 moves the end
uh so if you guys are really interested
in watching this uh you're welcome to
stick around and see what happened here
as
quite a lot happened in this game so
it's daniel dubov uh everyone's favorite
chess player against world champion
magnus carlsen
uh let's see what's happening here as
it's always very exciting when the two
of them meet
and not only have they worked together
uh dubo has also worked as a second for
magnus carlsen during his world champs
championship match
so they know a lot about each other and
it's always very interesting when when
they face each other
uh as you know every uh you know
every guy is trying to outsmart the
other guy since uh he basically knows
what the other guy knows so let's see
what's happening here duba
with the white pieces uh opens with d4
uh we have d5 by magnus c4 by double
uh we have c6 and knight to f3 magnus
goes for
knight to f6 knight to c3 and e6 now and
we have the semi-slav defense on the
board we have g3 by do both
knight beat the d7 and now bishop to g2
so just uh
the usual stuff bishop to e7 in both
players castle
castles castles and now b3 uh and here
we have b6 and black also wants the
fiance to his light square bishop now we
have bishop to b2
and now a5 by magnus and here
uh well you could uh go for knight to d2
it's the
uh most usually played move here uh
dubof goes for the immediate e4 now it
seems like it's a pawn sacrifice but not
really if you if you capture this
uh it doesn't really matter because
after for example capture you can just
shift the knight here and you're going
to win back the spawn it's attacked
three times
uh but interestingly this move was never
played knight captures an e4 is a known
move here and bishop to b7 is a known
move here
but the move magnus plays is a new move
so already as of move 10 we have a
completely new game magnus goes for
bishop to a6
and he puts pressure on the c for pawn
so dubo goes
knight to e5 he defends the c4 pawn now
and asks magnus if he is maybe
interested in capturing
an e5 but this doesn't really do
anything for him because after captures
and captures you don't have the option
of capturing since your knight is under
attack and now
we would probably see an all-out capture
fest with knight captures
knight captures here we're gonna see
pawn captures bishop captures
and now even the queens can come off the
board uh so
or or maybe you can play something like
bishop to b7 to guard the pawn here
but either way not a lot to be achieved
here so magnus instead after knight to
e5 goes rook to c8
adds another as a defender here to the
c6 pawn as the knight is attacking it
and now rook to e1 a very useful move as
the bishop would be attacking the rook
if the c pawn moved so here d captures
in c4
we have knight captures on c for bishop
captures and the b
capture so now magnus has given up the
bishop pair and duval has this beautiful
center here so
let's see what magnus had in mind as
this is uh it's looking
very very good for white so here duval
starts with
e5 uh sorry magnus starts with e5 uh he
wants the
if he wants either dubo to capture here
to get his knight into the game and mess
up his central pawn structure
uh or uh he's just gonna capture here so
duval prepares with
knight to e2 and now magnus goes to
bishop to b4 he chases the rogue back
and he says
that uh that now uh his position has
improved a little bit
and duba will have to figure out how to
develop this rook so rook to f1
and rook to e8 by magnus we have queen
to c2
and now comes queen to e7 maybe
capturing here wasn't all that all that
terrible but
um as usual if you're not gaining
anything by capturing you don't want to
capture
and here you're not really gaining
anything but capturing so magnus
decides against capturing this so
instead
after this uh move uh queen to c2 we
have queen to e7
uh and now duba finds the very
interesting c5 idea and this is
definitely something dubo had in his
home preparation because it's just uh
it's just amazing how he finds these
little
uh you know tricky moves in every
position possible i
i i mean he he just has all of these
positions uh in his head he he's uh
he's a true encyclopedia uh so
here the idea is if the pawn is captured
then the problem is the bishop cannot go
back
the bishop is trapped if b captures on
c5 you can just play a3 and that
bishop is trapped so obviously that's
not
not good for him so sorry about that i
just have to refresh the interface it
seems
seems to be frozen so just give me a
second
all right i don't know why but sometimes
it happens so do both plays c5
and now of course magnus doesn't capture
rather magnus plays e
captures on d4 first uh which is also
very interesting we have c
captures on b6 dubois creates a pass
pawn with the idea that if magnus
captures this he can always capture on
d4
but now magnus plays c5 magnus traps his
dark square bishop
voluntarily and duboff says all right we
have a3 and now your bishop is trapped
but magnus will have
a beautiful pawn chain here on the queen
side so he just grabs dovah's pass
pawn on b6 knight captures on b6 uh a
captures on b for a captures
in the now do both goes for knight to f4
rook the a6 is also very nice as it just
doubles up the rooks on the a file
with tempo as the knight on b6 is
undefended but okay do both goes for
knight to f4
shifting the knight over to d3 and now
queen to d6 by magnus uh we have rook
after d1
now keeping an eye on the pawns here one
thing you don't want to allow is that
for example this pawn reaches c4 and c3
because then it's just
uh much better for for black so here
luvo of course of course has to figure
out how to stop that here we have knight
beat to d7
magnus shifts the knight over to the
center maybe knight to the e5
is coming next and here rook eight to c1
so just keeping an eye on all of the
pawn pushes
and the situation on the clock is eight
minutes for duval and six minutes for
magnus
so queen to a a6 by magnus now again uh
keeping an eye on this
c4 square he is preparing to push those
pawns at some point
and knight to d3 now so what do you play
here uh here
uh instead of this knight to d3 also
bishop to h3
was maybe a possibility to make use of
uh
maybe awkward uh awkward placement of
black's pieces
uh but okay dubo went knight to d3 and
now magnus goes
h5 creates some breeding room for his
king and also he just wants to attack
that
uh king side so h3 now uh again
i will i will mention also possibly his
queen to c4 and then we would see
something like
queen characters rook captures and now
if knight captures an e4 bishop captures
an e4 and rook captures on e4 we would
have this position
where white is better but unfortunately
it's not all that easy to calculate
because you don't have knight captures
on b4 if you had this
it'd be excellent but then knight to b6
comes and you have problems now you have
to move the rook
and the black rook is defended so a b
captures
c captures on b4 is happening so it's a
very tricky position and although queen
to c4 makes sense it
does have its downside and well
both of them are now very very low on
time and it's very hard to calculate
this so
h3 instead by do buff and now comes
b3 by magnus so again a lot of
possibilities here
knight captures on e4 is always hanging
so magnus could always go for this pawn
but magnus goes for the tricky b a b3
move
and now the idea is if you capture with
the queen then this
double attack happens and if knight
before attacking the queen queen
to b5 now pinning the knight and again a
very complicated position
the knight cannot move the queen would
hang these two pawns are here
ready to march forward uh very tricky
position not something you want to face
in time trouble
so instead after that uh after queen b3
we have queen to c
for now offering finally this queen
trade and
magnus accepts we have queen captures
rook captures
and now finally knight captures on e4 we
have
bishop captures on d4 and this bishop
captures on d4 was maybe a bit premature
because it falls into the
uh uh falls for the same idea bishop
captures on e4 is a bit more precise but
okay
uh it's a rapid game uh we have bishop
capture on d4
and now not captures of course this
would be uh terrible
because you would just remove the
defender of the knight here so rook
captures bishop captures knight
and now white is just winning up a piece
and this pawn isn't really an issue
so here after bishop captures on d4 we
have knight the b6
attacking the rook and now uh we have
and also defending this rook so we don't
have any of the
of the other uh lines that we've shown
so here dubo goes for the absolute best
move
rook captures on c5 this was his plan
uh we have knight captures on c5 knight
captures on c5
attacking the b3 past pawn and now b2
saying that if you capture i'm gonna
pick up your knight here so dubo goes
back knight d3 with a double attack on
the pawn
and knight to c for now the knight now
is under attack so magnus has to move it
but now he also loses
the pass pawn so knight captures
uh on b2 and now we have rook eat a d8
uh just if this knight captures then
rook captures with a double attack on
the bishop and you will not be able to
move the the rook is on d1
so here bishop to c3 instead and only
now
knight captures on b2 rook rook capture
78 with check rook captures and the
bishop captures on b2
and it's only moved 36 and we already
have this amazing end game
where dubo has three pawns magnus has
three pawns
but it's the bishop pair against the
rook so can the mighty bishop
player overcome the rook here uh let's
see how they play this
so rook the d1 check magnus now has to
start and as usual
uh if you don't know in games like these
if
none of the pieces or pawns are captured
and if no pawn moves uh occur
then it's a draw at uh whenever 50 moves
are played so if we don't capture
anything and
if we don't move any pawns then it's a
draw after 50 moves and this is what
carlson of course is counting on
so he starts with a nice rook to d1
check we have bishop to f1
and now rook to b1 he goes after the
bishop bishop to d4
and rook to d1 so magnus is of course
happily chasing those bishops
bishop to e3 and now rook back to a1 so
asking duba what you
play here king g2 and now rook to a5 we
have king to f3
and now rook to f5 with check magnus of
course wants to
get as many moves in as possible king to
e4 and now rook back to a5 with bishop
to c4
and now rook to a4 forcing dubo to
defend the bishop king d5 and now
rook to a1 we have king to d6 dubo is
now trying to get his king over to e7 to
win the f7 pawn
but magnus says nope not happening he
goes king f8 and now
bishop to c5 threatening a nasty
discovery
by moving the king so rook to d1 with
check
king to c6 checking the black king and
king to g8
now uh we bishop to d5 and
now comes rook to d3 uh we have bishop
to e4 attacking the rook rook to d2 and
now bishop back to d5 magnus of course
now very happy to repeat the position
as only white can be pushing here so
rook d3 and the bishop now to e3
uh we have g6 by magnus now a pawn move
has been made so
uh the 50 move rule extends for 50 more
moves
so king to d6 and now comes king g7
so magnus is just waiting and uh maybe
uh
we're waiting to see what do we will do
so here king e5
and rook to d1 we have g for now
trying to trade off a pair of pawns
which magnus of course doesn't mind
we have h captures and g for h captures
and now again
rook to d3 uh we have bishop to g5 going
for some bishop to f6 check action
uh but nothing to worry about just rook
to d1 and
you don't really have to worry about
this the king if the king ever reaches
uh this square you will not be able to
move since uh
the the bishop will be pinned so bishop
f6
check king to f8 and now king to d6 but
again
magnus is asking how are you how are you
capturing this pawn
so rook to d2 going after this pawn and
now simply f3 the bishop now nicely
defends it and the pawn defends
the other pawn so look back to d1 bishop
to c3 now uh we have looked at d3
attacking the bishop
bishop to e5 rook back to d1 magnus is
very happy with the repetition
and duboff continues pushing f4 we have
looked at g1
and now g5 by duo so kind of restricting
that black king the black king will no
longer
be able to even if the bishop moves will
no longer be able to enter the game
so rook to d1 pinning the bishop here
and now comes king to c6 we have rook to
d2
and now bishop to d6 with check king g7
and now bishop back to d3 so uh you have
to make some quality moves but
there is not a lot of time as dubois is
down to some 30 seconds and i think
magnus was around two and a half minutes
here
so rook to d3 again magnus goes after
the bishop bishop to c4 and now
rook to d1 so here we're going to see a
lot of
repetition of moves because um there's
just not
all that great of a way to make progress
here so king d7 magnus tries to get his
king in closer rook d4
attacks the bishop bishop b5 and now f6
by magnus now magnus
as dubo allowed it plays f6 and now he
wants to trade off
the the other pawn as well king to e6
with a double attack on the pawn
now rookie for check we have king to d5
and rook back to e1
uh we have captures with check king
captures and now
bishop to e5 with check king e7 and now
bishop to d3 attacking the g6 pawn and
now
uh dubo will try to win that g6 pawn but
magnus of course will make it
incredibly hard for dubo to do so so
king f7 and now
bishop to c4 again threatening a
discovery with the king
but it's not really all that impressive
king e7 not allowing king to d6 and now
king back to d4 we have rook to a1
and bishop to d3 now attacking the uh g6
pawn here
so king of seven defending and now king
to d5
we have rook to d1 attacking the bishop
now king e4
rookie one check king to d4 and not rook
to d1 again magnus very happy repeating
moves
uh we have bishop to c7 and now king to
e7
the bishop cannot capture as it's been
king to e3 preparing to capture
and now rook to c1 by magnus attacking
the bishop here we have bishop to b6 and
now
now we have a very interesting position
where magnus has to bring his king
closer to this pawn
however magnus played rook to g1 and
in this one instance he gave dubo a
winning opportunity
so feel free to pause the video here and
try to find the winning idea for duba
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
only move that
wins here for white and for those of you
who just want to enjoy the show it's
kink to f3
that's the stuff and now you will see
why it's winning because now
there's a discovery here on the rook and
you cannot keep your rook on the g
file that's the problem so you have to
play something we have
rook to c1 by magnus and now
uh now comes king to g4 and this is a
very impressive play-by-do of capturing
the
capturing the pawn now runs into rook to
c6 with a double attack here
so that's uh not not sufficient so after
look to c1 king g4 by duba
excellent going after the pawn with the
king now uh we have rook to c3
attacking the bishop and now bishop to
e4
we have king to f7 defending the pawn
and now comes
bishop to d5 with check the king now has
to move king to e7
and now we have bishop to a5 attacking
the rook and this is one move where dubo
uh makes a mistake because now dubo has
to find the bishop to f2 bishop to e4
also works king the g5 also works but
this is the
kind of the simplest way as it prevents
the rook uh from reaching the g3 square
after the king goes to g5
problem here is after rook to c2
attacking the bishop you have bishop h
for
check and after king f8 now you play
bishop to e4 with a double attack and
you pick up the pawn
you cover the c6 square so the rook
cannot defend and also
uh the the g2 square and i believe that
this is in fact the wooden shield so
uh this was in the position for duba uh
you would have to see something like
rook c4 and bishop captures in g6 and
now dubo is winning
however after king e7 duba played rook
bishop to a5 first
but now he gives magnus a new lease on
life we have rook to c1
and now magnus will always be able to
use the rook to attack at least one of
the bishops
so bishop back to b6 but now comes rook
to d1
not allowing bishop to come to f2 as the
light square bishop is under attack so
bishop f3 attacking the rook and now
comes
rook to f1 again magnus gives dubo
a chance here rook to b1 you have to
keep attacking the bishops but magnus
plays rook to f1
and now again dubo has a great chance to
uh make something happen here uh if he
plays
bishop to e4 and bishop to e4 is very
nice here as
it now attacks the pawn and you don't
allow rook to g1 check and here after
king to f7 we have king g5 and now
you're just gonna pick up the pawn with
check but uh dubo was constantly playing
with
20 seconds on the clock constantly on
increment after rook to f1 duo played
bishop to g2
but now it's different now again he
gives magnus an opportunity to attack
one of the bishops so
rook to b1 attacking the bishop and now
bishop to c5 check king to f7 we have
bishop to e4 with
a double attack rook to e1 and now
bishop to d5 with chuck king g7 and now
bishop to f3 but now it's going to be
very hard for that king to reach the g5
square
rook the c1 again magnus continues
attacking the bishops bishop to e3 and
the rook to b1
now so uh now the king can reach the g5
square but then you will have a double
uh a nice double attack on the bishops
and also
uh it's uh uh uh just possible to check
the
uh white king along the the fifth rank
so here we have bishop to d4 check first
king to h6 and now bishop to c5 and now
the problem is that
carlson's king is much safer there than
than it was on e7 or f8 for example
king g7 we have bishop to e2 and not
rook to c2 and now magnus just has to
wait for
for the 50 move rule to kick in and he
will enjoy his
uh half point uh we have bishop to e3
reaching move 100 rook to e1 with a
double attack but it doesn't matter as
bishop d4 with check is coming king h6
bishop to f3
and again magnus uh defense successfully
there's no way to reach that g6 pawn so
here
rook b1 bishop to f6 rogue g1 check
king back to h4 rogue b1 bishop g5 check
king g7 and king to g3
there's no way to make progress here
rook b3 we have king to f2
and now rook to a3 uh king to a2 rook to
b3
bishop to e4 and now rook to a3 bishop
d3
rook to b3 and now king to e3 and here i
think dubo knew that
there's no way to do anything here but i
mean it doesn't cost anything to try and
only white can actually
win this if black maybe makes a blunder
so here
rook b4 bishop b4 rook to a4 we have
bishop d5
rook to be for king d3 rook to a4 and
now bishop to c4 so
there's simply no no way to reach that
g6 pawn rook a1 king d4
rookie one king b5 rookie one rookie one
check king e5
rookie one two king d6 rook d1 check
king is seven
rookie one check bishop to e6 and now
rook to e4
we have king to d6 and after rook to e1
we've reached move 122 and it was in
this position that the players uh
well they didn't agree to draw it was a
draw by 50 move rule
uh but uh just in case you didn't know
what that was this is what it looks like
so
really crazy stuff dooba playing a great
game magnus again
living on the edge but he doesn't care
because he already qualified so he can
uh you know enjoy a wild game against
dubois i don't think there's anything
greater than
enjoying a wild game against dubo and
there were chances so you can see it's
never never easy even though
objectively this is a draw the rook can
handle the the bishop pair but
uh we had twice in the position where
dubo had a winning idea but
i mean i mean with so little time on the
clock no no one can do this
as it would seem uh so yeah a tough
break for dubai i don't know if he will
be
able to qualify for for the rest of the
tournament we'll see how it goes in the
final round for him
uh and yeah i hope you guys enjoyed that
a nice uh nice
uh nice game of 122 moves
uh so i would like to thank richard
renegade tony moa guitar dragon urishic
mark wealth and juan m el sequi for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank all for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this very
nice tournament uh checking up on your
wonderful suggestions
and whatever else happens in the chess
world so uh thank you all i will see you
soon and
have an excellent rest of your day